[Music]
Harry what's up bro let's talk about the
new album man um yes
what's up what's going on man like
yesterday's tomorrow night so the album
starts when I finished cancer I was
diagnosed with Hodgkin's lymphoma it's
just like the inflammation of all the
lymph nodes in your body so you neck
your armpits your thighs or your groin
your stomach chest like every lymph node
you have just like inflation it's like
tumor but what is one thing that you
took away from the fight with cancer
live a life true to myself you get
diagnosed you think you think your whole
life has changed that day you think it's
over so you're like why this happened
you know and then you start realizing
like man I was a liar I stole I was like
you know like I wasn't true to myself I
don't I don't show my complete love I
don't show my complete self I'm making
music for the wrong reasons because I'm
not being true to myself because I'm
afraid yeah
you feel me and so then I was like you
know if I get out of this alive I'm a
live a life true to myself I'm gonna
make music true to myself I'm gonna help
people because I'm not the only one
going through pain and depression and
all this stuff like what's the hardest
song for you to perform love dad for
sure
why just because it's just is this song
that I wrote a couple months before my
dad passed right and I don't know why I
wrote it and there's the easiest song I
wrote I was just sitting on my back
porch one day and I just closed my eyes
and I brought this poem and it just
feels like my dad wrote that for me it's
like brew me will makes you happy
waking up everyday being around my
friends and family who you know then
creating what's one word that best
describe you and and why you're here
whoa
hope
[Music]
you